23. the nets are six of 23.
some terrific three-point shooting
[Applause]
durant now and if it's on tucker that's
going to be his fourth
as tucker and durant get into each
other's face
tucker now yelling at kyrie irving
if you're tucker you got to be smart
okay it's going to be a double technical
foul you don't want to pick up another
one
and be ejected out of this ballgame yeah
they'll be double technicals i wonder
if they might hand out another one for a
third player who came in
[Applause]
and that's a foul that's going to be his
fourth and durant said something right
after that now
face to face
that was appeared to be a security
coming in that
had to shove there see i think
it's hard to tell if tucker's yelling at
irving or the security guard who came
barreling in
well one of those i think it's a double
technical foul
yo that that's for sure and i think in
security you have to be secured and make
sure you're not elevating the issue
as opposed to controlling it
so these these two texas longhorns who
have a terrific relationship
the emotion of the playoffs taking over
security did a bad job you won't come in
pushing and shoving yeah
you're right mark